[Musique]
je gagne ma vie à travailler avec des
gens qui sont vraiment intéressés à
savoir qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire
pour être les meilleurs au monde
si le skieur acrobatique mikaël
kingsbury domine outrageusement son
sport c'est qu'en plus de ses habiletés
physiques
il a un mental d'acier cette force il
l'a forgée avec jean françois ménard qui
est un préparateur mental
après des années à pénétrer les cerveaux
des plus grands champions olympiques
il s'est dit pourquoi pas transposer son
savoir au monde du travail
y'a pas une autre domaine qui évolue et
hautain à quelles voies au niveau
technologique au niveau programmation
puis vous pour vraiment rester au top de
rester élite
il faut vraiment évolué vous avez
vraiment beau choix ce qu'il faut
surtout apprendre à évoluer c'est la
façon que vous utilisez votre cerveau
parce que c'est votre moteur comment
quelqu'un qui est sur une piste de ski
quelqu'un qui dans un bureau les
exigences de la tâche vont changer mes
métiers les habilités psychologique pour
vraiment bien performer il peut être
semblable ce qu'il y aurait le pain là
qui est en haut de la piste le puits qui
s'apprête à descendre pas sur une
colline qu est ce une pente qui est
comme seul puits qui voit ce qu'est prêt
de 125 lamerat auraient ils vont
utiliser la respiration consciente pour
être dans le moment pourrait être qu'un
pur est en contrôle pour profite à plein
de pensées négatives qu'ils dérangent
mais le travailleur le programmeur comme
que vous êtes tous peu importe le rôle
que vous jouez la respiration consciente
peut vous aider a justement ralentir vos
pensées justement vous concentrez qui
est vraiment ancrée parce que vous êtes
en train de faire
pour le fondateur de la firme aux aidés
à ces ateliers permettent à la fois
d'améliorer l'ambiance de travail
la créativité est bien sûr la
performance de l'entreprise
beaucoup de patients faut livrer
rapidement pour livrer avec qualité
peanutsie principal à sanaa est ce notre
cerveau
donc toutes les techniques qui sont
utiles pour les athlètes olympiques les
athlètes d'élite est responsable de
travail donc on veut avoir les meilleurs
outils pour que notre cerveau plus
performé les explications possibles
vous savez que rafael nadal comme joueur
de tennis il ya tendance des fois a
commencé ses matchs un petit peu là mais
il finit toujours en force
s'ils gagnent un match en cinq sets de
qui en a perdu 2,7 puis regagne 3 plus
souvent qu'autrement il va perdre les
deux premiers puits va gagner 3 dernier
puis la raison c'est que il célèbre et
une victoire arriver à l'heure au
travail le matin
pour certains c'est peut être une
victoire regrets ceux qui ont des
enfants vous le savez moi j'ai deux
jeunes enfants passe des choses pas
évident le matin d'organiser mme idrac
ya rien de trop petit que vous pouvez
pas célébrer puisque ce soit au niveau
de développer son attitude s'est levé
avec la pression célébrer des petites
victoires au lieu de célébrer la grosse
victoire
on cherche la médaille d'or plusieurs
fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]